How to ask a question on the Hugging Face forums?
If you have a general question or are looking to
debug your code, the forums are the place to ask.
In this video we will teach you
how to write a good question,
to maximize the chances you will get an answer.
First things first, to login on the
forums, you need a Hugging Face account.
If you haven't created one yet, go to hf.co and
click Sign Up. There is also a direct link below.
Fill your email and password,
then continue the steps ot pick a
username and update a profile picture.
Once this is done, go to discuss.huggingface.co
(linked below) and click Log In. Use the same
login information as for the Hugging Face website.
You can search the forums by clicking on the
magnifying glass. Someone may have already asked
your question in a topic! If you find you can't
post a new topic as a new user, it may be because
of the antispam filters. Make sure you spend some
time reading existing topics to deactivate it.
When you are sure your question hasn't been
asked yet, click on the New Topic button.
For this example, we will use the following code,
that produces an error, as we saw in the
"What to do when I get an error?" video.
The first step is to pick a category for our
new topic. Since our error has to do with the
Transformers library, we pick this category. New,
choose a title that summarizes your error well.
Don't be too vague or users that get
the same error you did in the future
won't be able to find your topic. Once
you have finished typing your topic,
make sure the question hasn't been answered
in the topics Discourse suggests you.
Click on the cross to remove that
window when you have double-checked.
This is an example of what not to do when
posting an error: the message is very vague
so no one else will be able to guess what went
wrong for you, and it tags too many people.
Tagging people (especially moderators) might
have the opposite effect of what you want.
As you send them a notification (and they get
plenty), they will probably not bother replying
to you, and users you didn't tag will probably
ignore the question since they see tagged users.
Only tag a user when you are completely certain
they are the best placed to answer your question.
Be precise in your text, and if you have an
error coming from a specific piece of code,
include that code in your post. To make sure your
post looks good, place your question between three
backticks like this. You can check on the
right how your post will appear once posted.
If your question is about an error, it's even
better to include the full traceback. As explained
in the "what to do when I get an error?' video,
expand the traceback if you are on Colab. like
for the code, put it between two lines containing
three backticks for proper formatting. Our last
advice is to remember to be nice, a please and a
thank you will go a long way into getting others
to help you. With all that done properly, your
question should get an answer pretty quickly!